en martinique comme en guadeloupe la
problématique de l'indivision
successorale paralyse en moyenne 45 % du
foncier
le texte de loi présenté par serge
letchimy adoptée à l'unanimité par les
députés en deuxième lecture a pour
objectif de faciliter la sortie de
l'indivision il permet de déroger à la
règle de l'unanimité et donc autorise le
ou les indivisaires titulaire de 51% des
droits de disposer du bien dans un délai
rapide a souhaité que ce n'est pas faire
seulement pouvoir relancer une politique
immobilière parce que je ne souhaite pas
du tout mon texte soit dans la
spéculation immobilière
ça permettra cette année dans l'élite
mais c'est surtout la reprise en main de
la restauration de notre patrimoine et
ça peut aussi avoir des conséquences à
devrait avoir des conséquences au plan
de la dynamique économique parce que la
restauration des quais relevé les coeurs
des boues dans nos communes martinique
guadeloupe guyane et grands ça passe par
une réappropriation de l'immobilier
abandonné autre point fort de ce texte
l'annulation des droits de partage de
2,5 pour cent appliqué jusque-là lors
d'une rupture d'indivision essentielles
n'ont pu obtenir que ce soit levé et
ainsi j'ai bon espoir que dans les dix
ans à venir
et bien que les terres de nos ancêtres
la terre de ce qui effectivement au
peuple est depuis longtemps nos
territoires puissent revenir à nos
enfants et à nos petits enfants
ainsi ils pourront par exemple utiliser
cette terre pour construire leur maison
pouvoir hypothéquer obtenir auprès ça
n'était pas le cas auparavant je suis
fier fier que pour une fois et je
regarde mon collègue serge letchimy dans
les yeux et je lui dis très amicalement
je suis fier de constater d'observer que
pour une fois
l'indivision ne nous aura pas diviser
tous sont d'accord pour dire qu'il
s'agit là d'une avancée majeure pour
permettre aux familles de sortir de
difficultés considérables et pour
relancer la politique du logement en
outre mer